Did you get a Tesla?
Are you just driving around?
Oh God.
One telling me.
How do you like it?
I had to get one.
I told you long Moscow,
get one guy did my podcast.
I almost solid.
I'm a man of my word.
Uh,
it's a fucking spaceship.
It's the weirdest thing I've ever driven in my life.
It doesn't even make sense.
It's not even,
not even,
there's not a single car that I've ever driven that's even close to his fast.
Nothing like my Porsche is so slow.
I have a gt three Rs.
It has 518 horsepower.
It weighs 300 pounds.
It sounds like a dragon.
And that Tesla would leave it in the dust.
I mean,
leave it in the dust like zero to 62 seconds quicker.
It's fucking insane.
And out of a no ludicrous.
Oh yeah,
I did.
I put it in chill mode for a little while.
But you could drive chill with ludicrous mode.
Always available.
You don't have to keep switching back.
And ludicrous mode is just crazy crap.
Like the fastest and any kills your battery.
Well,
it kills your battery quicker.
But the thrust that you get is a rollercoaster ride.
It's insane.
I mean you can't believe how fast it is.
It doesn't even,
it literally doesn't make sense.
It doesn't seem right.
It seems like like it's punching its way through a wormhole.
Use an alien technology.
Meanwhile I posted,
it seems like a something Bob Lozar snuck out of area 51 I get all these
messages from people.
Bob was our has been debunked.
That's controlled opposition.
That's a fake story.
It's fake news bro.
They got you with the Bob Lozar story.
Do you like all the tech in it?
And I mean that's,
that's saying it's too much almost because it's this giant screen.
Like I had a dim at whey the fuck down cause I was just looking at it like
you're so pretty.
Pretty.
It's so pretty.
My dream car,
it's very comfortable.
Super comfortable.
Now do you have a supercharged station at your house yet or do your thing on the
wall at my house that I could plug it into?
It's on a supercharger.
It takes like eight hours,
10 hours or more.
And how many miles?
But I'm going to get one of those.
I'm going to get one of those fast charger in the house.
He goes allegedly,
and I mean allegedly 311 miles.
You have the fuel that put the,
here's the problem.
I drive like a moron.
So it's not going that far.
Did you get,
is there a few option for that model and like are you all,
I mean I think there's a fuel add on that gives you an exterior like,
oh,
that's an option.
Like I thought you meant a fuel like gasoline.
Yeah,
I know.
What are you talk some models,
not Tesla.
Okay.
You're just making shit up bro.
Some,
some,
uh,
I think it which car it is,
four wheeled electric cars to pay extra for like one gallon of gas.
So like if you ever lose your battery,
I have heard of that.
Yeah.
What was that?
I thought Tesla had that.
No,
no,
no.
There was like a Prius.
Prius is our mixed,
they're hybrids.
Prayas is use gasoline,
but a very stingy amount of gasoline.
They run partially on electric motors.
So do a,
the Acura Nsx,
the ACURA NSX has two electric motors,
but I think you don't ever charge it.
I think the electric motors are powered by the gasoline engine and electricity
in the car.
If I remember right,
that's supposed to be the motherfucker like the Acura Nsx is supposed to be the
car that people are underlooked under looking for whatever reason.
It just doesn't get the love that it deserves.
And apparently the 2019 models even more insane.
Right.
I can't wait to the day where like your garage floor is like a wireless charging
mat.
You just pull right up into that Matt or they would never would be because it's
rubber.
Well there I'm sure they'll find a way because it's like there's a,
there's,
there's like a view,
if you take her phone and put it on a wireless charger,
there's like a little room that if you don't,
you don't have to touch it.
Like maybe that's the whole reason why you're safe from getting hit by
lightning,
bro.
Yeah,
I like that.
The rubber protects you from electric park though a little thing comes down to
the ground,
like a little switch.
That thing falls out while you're driving a little bone,
wax your car over or did they give the streets?
Like if somehow like if you were riding on the highway and if you'd want to fuel
up that you can like fuel up using the road,
they might pay like a fee or something.
But really ideally it would be great if solar panels had gotten so powerful they
could charge it just with the sun.
Especially because southern California is always fucking sunny except for today,
but it's a matter of time.
The cars,
the future.
That's what it is.
It really is.
Look,
I'm a giant fan of American muscle cars there.
My all time favorite cars in terms of like to drive to hear the rumble of the
engine and that I love them.
I love them.
Maybe I'm some crazy old dude from the fucking eighties it's still loves 1960s
and muscle cars.
Maybe I don't care.
I love him,
but that fucking cars,
that future,
that Tesla's the future.
Like when you drive it,
you realize,
Oh,
other cars are stupid.
Is that,
that's that new world,
new crazy rocket thing today shooting rockets out in his backyard.
Is that his house?
Is there anything that you don't like on that or something that kind of bugs
you,
that you wish was like,
Oh I don't,
you know,
I don't like have,
there's no door handles,
you know?
No,
no,
nothing.
You just got to figure it out.
It just takes a little while to figure out what all different buttons do and how
to,
how to get things to happen.
But it's really well thought out.
It's a look.
He's a legit genius,
you know,
and what he's doing is unprecedented and you know,
this is going to sound like I'm kissing his ass cause I liked him because he did
the podcast and then I became friends with them.
No,
he's important.
The guys got ideas that are of a magnitude that dummies,
like you and me are never going to come up with any of those ideas ever.
If we lived a thousand lives,
we would never figure out space x.
It's just not in our wheelhouse.
We would never make a fucking electric car.
We never make one of those things.
Never got that Tesla roadster that's going to come out.
That goes zero to 60 in 1.9 seconds and looks like like a space ship,
like a like a race car spaceship from the future.
And we're not doing that dude.
We need people like that.
Those guys are super important.
This guy is a,
he's like a,
a culture,
like a legit culture changer and he got him to smoke weed.
Jesus you want to do,
is the ad blocker a bus to,
I'm looking forward to the new Toyota Super Man.
Super skying up dude.
The new one looks dope,
pat.
So this is the space x rocket.
So space.
What does it say at the top?
It says,
built a stainless steel rocket ship in Texas that looks like liquid silver and
might launch in February,
didn't it?
What year?
What Day is this?
Uh,
article.
January 11th.
A couple weeks?
Yeah.
Okay.
It fell over.
Yeah,
I know that they've been doing stuff more with it,
but I just,
how cool it looks.
It looks like it fell on the ground while I was standing there.
Yeah.
It got blown over in the wind.
It looks like a drawing for a rocket from the 19 hundreds I don't know if he did
it on purpose,
but it looks just like,
it looks like a fucking movie.
Like buck Rogers.
That's a book.
Rogers rocky.
Right.
It looks dope though.
Roger's dude that driving that car really feels like the future.
And did you get the best model or
of course you did,
but uh,
yeah,
I got the model s p 100 ds.
What it's called.
I just paid off my car.
I might just sell and get one of those.
You have to have a place to park it that has a little charge port.
A power outlet.
I don't think you'd probably convert it.
Yeah.
I think there's a couple of superchargers in Burbank and yet there's one across
the street,
but it's always taken.
I don't know what the,
you know what's weird man pass and by gas stations and going,
I'm never gonna use you with this.
I'm never pulling in there unless I want a soda.
Look at that thing.
That's why zero to 60 in 1.9 seconds and I'm telling you,
man,
that's not an unrealistic number.
620 miles.
Yes.
Wait,
when's this come out?
A couple of years.
It's going to be awhile.
Uh,
I'm going to get 100% I'll buy your old one.
This is such a dope car,
man.
It doesn't even make sense.
Why does it not have a side mirror?
It's got no side mirrors as cameras.
Fuck the rendering of it.
Shut your mouth.
I tell you,
God damn side mirror you sons of bitches.
I love my camera.
Camera's on my car.
I don't even use my side mirrors.
It's so much better having that look at that thing.
How much is that?
620 mile.
I Dunno.
Probably stupid.
Expensive.
Look how pretty it is.
It's too pretty to be cheap.
I got fucking sick.
That thing looks,
look at it.
I mean it's like the ultimate sports car,
like that looks like a,
that easily could be a new nine 11 like from that angle particularly and then
the roof comes off.
It's like gamer seats.
Look at this game.
Receipts right there.
Well not only that,
but,
well that's what racing seats,
but that's why they were racing seats first and then we came gamer.
She when the steering wheel's wonky steering wheels like a,
like an f one,
like a Formula One car.
See it.
Oh it's like square.
Yeah.
It's like grab it by the handles.
Maybe they want to make sure that you don't do this kind of shit like,
ew,
this is so fast.
You probably need to hold onto it in a different way.
Dude,
I'm telling you that the car that I,
that I got beautiful.
I've never experienced anything like that before.
And you don't think it's real.
You don't think a car can do that?
Doesn't make any sense.
Why did you wonder if $45,000
damn chop that chat on my gosh.
Plus the five thousand fifty thousand to up two 50 yeah.
It's probably gonna sell out in five seconds to to pay it.
Every,
every dickhead in Hollywood will have one.
Look at me.
I'm environmentally conscious,
but still sucks.
Like I'm gonna be talking about open shirt to Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo.